may the 4th be with you in star wars
down go sky feels like it comes early
and early every year but don't may the
4th here it is even though we're
dedicating this whole show to Star Wars
or Star Wars guess so earth Clips star
wars underoos damn I'm wearing Jar Jar
Spanx 3 so balls are sweaty we didn't
want to go overboard after all it's just
some movies right who would take Star
Wars dude seriously well maybe a man
named Jojo Abrams who told the
conference in Beverly Hills Star Wars
isn't a movie it's a religion he started
to say more but was immediately burned
at the stake for the sin of not
including Han Solo's fuzzy dice the
Millennium Falcon
so comedians if Star Wars is in fact a
religion what is the Star Wars
commandment
so we altered the buzzers a little right
Alex
honor thy father and mother unless your
father is a dark Sith Lord and then
released your couple hair marries and
yeah all right Ashley thou shalt not
assume that the Ewoks are tiny bears all
right yes what no you know what they are
the Ewoks hang on the Ewoks are just
small inbred house wookies like someone
tried to breed over a Gothel house
wookie and so that's you know they have
those little shih tzu faces they have
like it's like the same they have all
the same congenital birth defects that
shih tzus have from just years of injury
and they're terrible pets so big try to
eat you they're terrible pets like
you're constantly like the poop cakes
and their fur cuz they're bipedal and
lustily and you try to clean them and
they're just like you up and you're like
yeah I know yeah yup no I got to get to
work man come on chill out stop trying
to put me on a spit make sure they're
spayed and neutered yeah big shipping
today is we're we're young
hang on can I blow your mind wookie II
walk the same letters the same
animal alien sort of anyway heavy john
dimaggio thou shalt not worship any
false idols especially that dick gene
roddenberry yeah